the problem we have is that the damage
we caused to the global environment is
not reflected in the price of the energy
we consume right that's the most basic
definition of the problem with we have
if you bring even partly the the cost
what we call the external cost of your
facility or consumption into the price
of energy you raise your price is a bit
higher or much higher if you do it if
you do it meaningfully there's no way
around that yes addressing climate
change is all about changing the
relative prices of energy to make the
carbon intensive ones relatively more
expensive and the carbon less intensive
one relatively less expensive actually
it's all about what the public will
believe and what they will take in the
way of messages public can't believe
whatever they want the ton of co2 ton of
corner and oxidation a democracy the
action matters well well they did that
wasn't oh that wasn't the point that we
could be heard air it was Mike Mike
Stevens who pointed out that it was a
real problem what the public believed
well and and what he can do and the
power of those who have got authority of
the elegance in order to convey the
right message the saving the world
message of our goal is absolutely
hopeless it is not convincing anybody at
all